all right yesterday we spoke with the
computer repair shop owner at the center
of
zero experience hunter biden scandal
john
paul mack isaac he shared a story and
provided exclusive details regarding the
content
on hunter's hard drive and the documents
that show
very high likelihood joe lied to the
country when he said he had no knowledge
of hunter's business dealings
we did reach out to hunter biden's
attorney for comment
some reason they just won't get back to
us as promised
part two of our exclusive hannity
interview
now you're visually impaired but yet
through the aid of devices i mean this
is intricate work
i would assume working on computers
right
uh yes i the screws are small
the tools are pretty small luckily
there's a lot of visual aids i use
magnifying glasses monocles i even have
a microscope that
helps me do the close end work all right
now
your you believed that it was hunter
biden that dropped off
these laptops it's now didn't they
since all of this broke didn't they call
you and ask for the laptops back
surprisingly no nobody's uh approached
me to collect the machine
no no there wasn't an attorney that
called i had read an article there was
an attorney that had called seeking
oh okay how do you know
i would say go ahead sir october 13th uh
the day before the
new york post uh broke the story i did
get a call from an attorney representing
hunter uh
wanting to see if i still was in
possession of the equipment he made
reference that hunter was in sometime in
and dropped it off so i uh
okay i asked for his contact information
and he's got an email
okay now at the time he dropped off
three laptops in your store
uh only one of which was salvageable
which is the one in question correct
correct okay now you finally
you got to a point where you saw things
on the laptop
that were disturbing what did you see
i saw material of a very personal nature
i don't want to obviously go into it i
don't feel comfortable about talking
about
the the personal stuff i also saw files
related to financing and other documents
that uh
just raised some red flags let me
let me see if i can get you to explain
in a little more detail
things of a personal nature
anything that would shock the conscience
of the american people if they saw it
i i don't know about shocking the
conscience of the american people
i know that in the process of trying to
verify data
you want to choose files that are going
to be the most
susceptible to having corruption video
files are a good example of that
so when i was comparing the data from
the drive that i was copying to and from
i would open up a large video file and
then i saw some disturbing
uh content of a very personal nature
so of a personal nature let me ask you
this
would would your initial gut reaction
be one that would be this is
illegal what i'm saying what i'm seeing
rather
i didn't look at it in your in your
non-lawyerly opinion
in other words would an average person
looking at those videos
think this is totally illegal and and
needs to be reported
initially the stuff that i saw from
doing just the initial transfer
it did i would say the the images and
the video that i saw
i didn't i saw criminal activity but i
wouldn't go so far as to say it was
criminal i was more concerned about
later on
when the ukraine was topical in the news
during the summer of 2019
that's when i was getting more concerned
because i was seeing a lot of names and
a lot of numbers
that again i felt somebody would someday
come looking for this laptop and i
needed to get it out of my shop